أعلنت العائلة المالكة للتو أن
اختبار الأمير تشارلز إيجابي
لفيروس كورونا ، فلننتقل مباشرة إلى ماكس فوستر على شبكة سي إن إن ،
وهو يعيش خارج لندن ،
ما هي حالته كحد أقصى حالته
هي أنه تم اختباره إيجابيًا ، إنه
في اسكتلندا حاليًا في منزله هناك
إنه منزل خاص  هناك كان
يظهر عليه أعراض خفيفة
لا تزال في حالة صحية جيدة وكان
يعمل من المنزل طوال
الأيام القليلة الماضية كالمعتاد ، ومن الواضح أن هذا إيجابيًا
يمثل مصدر قلق كبير لأنه في
أوائل السبعينيات من عمره أنه مصاب بهذا الفيروس وهو
في المجموعة المعرضة للخطر التي يتواجد فيها
دوقة كورنوال كاميلا ، يتم
اختبارها لأنها ليست مصابة بالفيروس الذي
يتبعه جميع النصائح المناسبة
التي قيل لنا إن الاختبارات
أجريت في اسكتلندا حيث يوجد حاليًا من قبل
الخدمة الصحية وقد استوفى
المعايير المطلوبة للاختبار ولكن  في
هذه المجموعة الضعيفة ، من الواضح أن
هذا يثير القلق بشأن من كان
على اتصال به أيضًا واهتمامنا الأول
لكونها الملكة ، لذلك
كنت أتحدث إلى قصر باكنغهام
ولم تكن على اتصال به
مؤخرًا في 12 مارس بعد
تنصيبها ، لذا فهي مصدر قلق
لأنها تتبع النصيحة المناسبة
فيما يتعلق برفاهيتها.
التسعينيات بعد كل شيء وقد أخبرنا أنها
لا تزال في صحة جيدة